Gavin nuum signed Bill 418 which will
prohibit any food containing brominated
vegetable oil potassium bromate propil
paraben and red D 3 California becomes
the first US state to ban Skittles and
12,000 additional products for cancer
causing additives what's going on it's
hard to uh take a Firm Stance on this
because on the one hand I do think it's
largely virtue signaling and perhaps a
bit of fear Mong ing you know California
is kind of known for doing that a lot of
products that are sold in California for
example like coffee and a product as
innocuous as instant coffee has to come
with the warning label that it contains
acrylamide a compound that in vitro at
least is a is a known carcinogen right
you can like find this on instant coffee
sold in California um it's not uncommon
to be in a parking garage for example
and see a sign in uh you know by the
elevator or staircase that the by being
in the parking garage you're going to be
exposed to chemicals known to cause
cancer and that are you know teratogenic
birth uh defect causing so California is
known for being a bit of a hypochondriac
State um and uh and so that's where I
think a lot of this comes from on the
other hand I am I'm not a fan of big
government I'm a fan of small government
and less regulation as opposed to more
but I do kind of think that where
regulation is perhaps warranted is in
with regard to the food supply the food
system
because if you let the market decide you
end up with things like Mountain Dew
flavored hot dogs which we've seen go
viral on social media or yeah I mean
these are it's unclear whether or not
these were real or computer generated
but I mean you see all the time you you
know there's like all kinds of crazy
products in the supermarket that are
just you know their sole intent
seemingly is to hook consumers onto this
addictive hyper palatable hyper calorie
dense product um you Eed in fast food
all the time I mean I'm not sure what
country I was in but I was walking
around and there was like a glazed dut
hamburger that some Mega chain was
offering somewhere um so like if you let
the market decide the market is
ultimately going to cater to what the
people want and people don't have like
stop gaps you know old roads lead back
to Haribo tangfastics or something yes
there you go exactly those those kinds
of products so I do think that a little
bit of
Regulation uh is important and I think
you know this this perhaps is a step in
the right direction because we know that
the food supply is essentially toxic we
live in a world now where 73% of items
in your average Supermarket are Ultra
process this is according to a new study
that came out that used a machine
learning algorithm that looked at all
the products available to your average
consumer in your average supermarket and
the vast majority of them are ultr
processed which we know has been linked
to every poor health outcome imaginable
these days so you know when when Banning
or at least regulating these kinds of
products which at the end of the day
ultimately are proxies for
ultra-processed foods like you're not
going to find red Dy 40 right in
something that mom
cooks I think that's a positive thing
but again California is known for
fearmongering I don't necessarily know
how evidence-based the the the the fear
that a lot of the a lot of people have
towards these products um are you know
the the reason the reason aspartam
controversy was a good sort of example
of that um I don't have a dog in the
fight with regard to aspartame
you know there's you can find equivocal
evidence that diet sodas are you know
actually very helpful with regard to
weight loss you can find observational
evidence that people who consume more
diet sodas have higher risk of obesity
higher risk of you know other negative
Health
outcomes but you know the World Health
Organization came out and said that it
was a possible human carcinogen which
the data on that isn't really so black
and white give me the yeah I've had so
many conversations about aspartame over
the last six months since that World
Health Organization thing came out uh
some people have said most people have
said uh the risks are overblown yeah the
concern doesn't matter unless you're
taking 8,000 Cokes a day or something
that the risk is so small then a lot of
people say well a small chance of cancer
risk increase isn't a good thing then
other people have said well the
reduction in weight from switching from
sugar calorie drinks to non calorie
aspartame drinks think about the
difference that you get now in terms of
weight loss and the downstream benefit
like what's your read overall how
worried should people be about
artificial sweetness yeah I don't I
don't think that people should be that
worried I this is where I think the the
limitations of data come in and you have
to you have to arrive at a set of values
about these sorts of products and for me
personally I avoid artificial sweeteners
because I
abide by what is sometimes referred to
as the precautionary principle you know
and you might say oh it's sort of like
borderline appeal to Nature fallacy but
I think that the less time a food or
product has been um in the marketplace
the more skepticism the more caution we
should reserve for that product and yes
Aspartame is one of the most studied
compounds in existence really well
particularly with regard to a consumable
product right but there's also
publication bias it's a heavily
commercialized product
and so for me I choose to avoid like
artificial sweeteners I don't think that
consuming them particularly in
reasonable doses is is going to be a
health concern and certainly for people
who are on weight loss diets and it is
the sort of the One Singular Vice that
allows them to better adhere to that
diet I think that's a positive thing um
and ultimately we're exposed to
carcinogens innumerable carcinogens on a
daily basis I think ultimately how to
prevent cancer is to you know to stack
the odds in your favor by building your
own resilience your own robustness with
exercise with an antioxidant-rich diet
um and the like so if a little bit of
aspartame sneaks in here and there which
I personally avoid but again if if if
this is something that happens to be
your Vice and you're consuming it in
reasonable doses I think it's probably
fine what is your advice to somebody
like me who has quite a strong Sweet
Tooth and has managed to condition
myself into eating a savory and then
looking for something just that's like a
little finisher at the end right and a
lot of the time I can make this work
with blueberries or raspberries
sometimes they're not in the fridge
sometimes it's like GH more blueberries
and raspberries what what are your go-to
I have a sweet tooth craving and I need
to satiate that but I don't want to kill
myself yeah where do you where do you go
and where do you advise people to go you
and Steven Bartlett he asked me the same
question did he yeah he was like it's a
br it's the British thing in us or maybe
it's the fact that we're both both from
like super working class backgrounds and
we're like we've been given this sort of
zero some scarcity mentality around
sweet things that it's a treat I don't
know yeah it's I mean it's great I look
I have a sweet tooth too I think we're
programmed for that right I mean sweet
is for one of our hunter gather
ancestors the only time they would
encounter the sensation of sweet sweet
taste right would be when fruit was
finally ripe during the summer season
and it would signal to your body to
store fat right it causes an elevation
of insulin it floods your muscles with
stored for later use right so we're
hardwired to enjoy sweet and
particularly today when sweet is
combined with salty when it's combined
with fatty you get this hyper palatable
combination sometimes referred to as the
Dorito effect right it takes uh a food
that was previously an ingredient and it
turns it into this this concoction that
pushes your brain to a bliss Point
Beyond which self-control is seemingly
impossible right I've gone through it
I've you know went I've gone to my
freezer taken out the pine of ice cream
only aspiring to have a spoonful or two
before you know I knew it I was looking
at the bottom of the Pint so I mean
that's kind of the problem with modern
Foods um but ultimately I think you know
with sweet there are a number of
non-caloric sweeteners on the market
that I think are relatively safe I mean
alos is a naturally derived sweetener
that I have no and I have no commercial
affiliation with any alos producer or
anything like that but there seems to be
some evidence that it might even be
might even actually uh have health
benefits associated with it um I think
arrol is great arrol is a a sugar
alcohol but among the sugar alcohols
it's the more well tolerated one some of
them can draw water into the gut and
have like a laxative effect which you
don't want it's like here's a chocolate
bar sweetened with malol and sorbitol
oops you're going to get diarrhea if you
eat more than half the bar but um but
arol is generally very well tolerated
like no one's going to go and buy arrol
and like throw it at a thing like what's
the food give me some foods that are
going to saate me well fruit I think is
great yep
um look ice cream you know there there's
observational evidence it's like
mind-blowing but that people who consume
ice cream for whatever reason they seem
to have better health you know I think
this is presumably that's going to be a
type of ice cream it's got It's not
going to be you know your Ultra
processed get it from an ice cream truck
thing yeah no I mean if you think about
it humans have been making ice cream for
quite some time and the ingredients in
I'm not saying that ice cream is a
health food by the way just to make that
perfectly clear and this is a perfect
example of where cor correlation doesn't
equal causation necessarily but um but
yeah ice cream I mean if you can buy
like uh you know ice cream made in the
traditional way I mean it's egg yolks
right it's it's heavy cream which is
actually heavy cream is a great source
of vitamin K2 like there's nutrients in
in ice cream so if you could find a low
sugar version of it you know let's just
take that there are nutrients in ice
cream that's all I needed to hear there
are actually that was that was all I
wanted but yeah I think um it makes me
think reflecting on my own sort of
dietary habits that uh Sweet Craving
that I've created in myself sometimes
after I have a big meal and uh unless
I'm very disciplined that can lead me
down a a very dangerous path you
mentioned about kind of this uh unique
blend of particular types of ingredients
particular types of
flavors have you ever seen hunter
gatherer tribes trying cheesecake for
the first time no is that a thing
there's videos of it on the internet
whoa so they give people who've never
had processed foods before and you think
about cheesecake from a taste design uh
horific you familiar with that no so
orifices are designed to make them more
palatable don't really think about this
right because the obsession is with
what's in the food but the way that it
feels in your mouth is a big determinant
of your enjoyment of it uh ancestrally
it would have been very very rare to to
have found something that had both
crunchy and fluffy uh and if you think
about some of the most palatable Foods
Oreos you know you've got this sort of
crunch and then fluff french fries same
thing again cheesecake you've got that
but really dialed up with this perfect
ratio of carbs and fat and sugar yeah
there's tart across the top if you've
got like a little fruit compt type thing
and you just get this like blast of this
Orchestra right in your mouth they give
it to these under gatherer tribes and
their faces you know someone that's just
chewed leaves right for the last decade
and and eaten meat that's been cooked in
variable like
qualities uh and yeah you realize how
hypernormal the stimuli of the foods
that we're eating are and this is the
biggest lesson that I took from you and
it's been really really useful for me
that one of the main problems with ultr
processed foods is not just what's in
them but it is the fact that eating to
sa satiety is so tough to do because it
is built to push you past satiety
exactly yeah super well said that's um
you know I used to be more admittedly
and this is an area where I've evolved I
used to be more interested in what is
the what is the more optimal mix of
carbs and fat for a for example a weight
loss diet or even for longevity and I
think now where the science is sort of
has has sort of um evolved and also my
thinking has evolved as well is that
it's really it's about food quality at
the end of the day and ultimately Ultra
process this term Ultra process which
was devised coined by in the the Nova
nutrient profiling system which was
devised in Latin America so people can
go look it up it's there's actually a
definition around what it takes to be
classed as an ultr processed food um
it's a good screening tool it's not even
necessarily the best diagnostic tool
because certainly there are some Ultra
processed foods which are quite healthy
you know you could take like a legume
based pasta which is uh you know an
certainly a processed food might not
necessarily be an ultra processed food
but processing is a Continuum and
certainly there are some ultr processed
foods that are healthy you know like a
dark chocolate bar is is you know fairly
processed at this point and it's uh and
it can be quite healthy we know that
cacao cocoa flavanols are really quite
beneficial to you but by and large the
vast majority of foods that Americans
today are consuming are Ultra processed
and we know that these Foods typically
are very nutrient poor so they're
depleted of any real nutritional quality
other than perhaps energy and and they
are incredibly calorie dense and they're
hyper palatable which makes them really
difficult to um to moderate so this uh
seminal study published a couple years
ago now two or three years ago funded by
the ni found that when people eat to eat
Ultra processed foods to satiety they
end up consuming a calorie surplus of
about 500 additional calories and today
in the united that's a pound of weight
per week right 3,500 calories a week is
a pound of weight gain per week
precisely yeah so and you know your
average American today that is largely
what your average American is doing
every day they're consuming 60% of their
calories from these Ultra processed
foods in the UK it's a little bit lower
it's about 50% yeah yeah so you guys are
doing a little bit better than we are
over here but American children are
consuming 70% Ultra processed foods and
it's only trending up it's like it's not
getting better it's getting worse and
we're now seeing connections between
Ultra processed food like dose responses
between ultr processed food consumption
and all cause mortality and risk for
cancer and risk for I mean dementia even
depression depression is linked with
ultra processed foods yeah I mean we're
at the very tip of the iceberg with this
in in in this field which is being
called nutritional Psychiatry looking at
the role that diet plays in mental
health but there have been a number of
associational studies at this point
linking poor diet to worse mental health
outcomes like clinical depression and
the like the question has always been
the direction of causality right so
depressed people obviously like when I'm
depressed I'm reaching for Comfort Foods
right ult which tend to be ultr
processed can eating more
ultra-processed Foods actually create
symptoms of depression that's been the
sort of looming question well we now
have randomized clinical evidence like
empirical clinical data suggesting that
when people on junk food diets clean up
their diets and adopt a more
Mediterranean style approach which the
Mediterranean diet is lauded in the
western literature as being the ideal
human diet I think it's it's one of
probably many ideal diets it's just a a
less processed diet at the end of the
day and a Diet that's more palatable to
that is palatable to Western pallets
that when people adopt a more uh
Mediterranean style diet they see some
they see remission from depression three
times the at at three times the rates as
compared to standard of care which was
shown in the smile trial which is sort
of one of these like it was the first
and still highly regarded highly cited
uh trials in this field of nutritional
Psychiatry run at the food and mood
Center at Deacon University in Australia
so yeah so food I mean food is medicine
and that and and depression has been
linked to inflammation we know that
inflammation is we can modulate it you
know via our diets and our lifestyles
not for every this isn't the case for
every person but there's certainly a
subset of the depressed population for
whom inflammation is likely playing a
role and there's a feedback back Loop
going on here right like the fact that
you don't know which direction the arrow
of causality is going in means that it
could actually be cyclical right that we
get depressed so we eat food which
worsens the way we feel which worsens
the depression which dude I I remember
so I've spoken about this on the show
before throughout a good bit of my 20s I
thought I had like ambient depression
that would creep up and then it would
break through the activation energy
surface and then it would go away again
and how depression would manifest for me
is I would stay in bed for maybe you
know 2 days at a time and I would refuse
to get out of bed but I would eat and
one of the things that I would do is I
would comfort I guess binge uh and it
would be very sugary very sort of just
like Comfort eating foods and there's a
sensation that you get if you really
pump your like you know like a couple of
muffins for breakfast and a few slices
of pizza or whatever it is that you want
to order from uberit or something and
there is a sensation you get especially
if you haven't moved you haven't got out
of bed you haven't seen any sunlight and
it presumably is the inflammation
response where it almost feels like your
body's sort of throbbing like in a
satisfactory way and your joints feel a
little bit tight and your brain feels
very foggy and then presumably off the
other side of this absolutely huge
glucose Spike I was able to then like
fall back asleep so I would do that you
know I'd wake up get food eat feel like
[__] like put Netflix on or whatever
curtains would be closed wouldn't want
to see anybody you know like meet the
guy at the the door the it sounds like
I'm getting my [__] MDMA dealer to
come around here like he also came
around but he came around at different
times
and that would be that would be part of
my cycle of of of low mood uh and it
absolutely facilitated it and I I used
food Ultra processed highly palatable
foods that spiked my blood
sugar as a a a comfort tool and it
absolutely made me and here was the
other thing it's not just about what you
eat and the way that it makes you feel
it is the story that you tell yourself
about the sort of person that you are
for having eaten that kind of food yeah
right and that is that's really the sort
of ruminative narrative based I am a
kind of person that does the XY Z that's
what I think really sort of drove it
home for me and made me feel like
particularly like unsatisfied with
myself I'm like look I shouldn't be
doing this like I understand how
important health and fitness is I go to
the gym I'm in good shape I was a
[__] commercial model for 15 years in
the UK like you shouldn't be lying in
bed eating duffins which is a a
combination dut muffin that was created
in the UK there you go don't let the
market decide all roads descend into the
hell that is duffins uh but yeah and you
know I think that Comfort eating but in
fact that's something I'd love to know
about from you like what is
it have you got any idea why people
Comfort B eat like what's going on there
are they reaching for something that's
like a
psychological uh piece of tape to like a
psychological bandaid of ss yeah I think
you know when you when you eat high
sugar foods there's a I mean it can it
can depress levels of cortisol which is
like the stress
hormone um we know that people that are
like for example fasting you can I mean
fasting is a stress response right so
sometimes when we're stressed out We
crave food because it's a a way of
signaling to our biology that
everything's okay because ultimately
food is a really important we've solved
for the food scarcity issue but for a
long time I mean food was the
primary
um variable right that would indicate
and like one of our ancestors successes
or or ultimate demises right um whether
or not they they were able to procure
food and we've done that and now that's
sort of become the double-edged sort of
modernity is that like food is available
constantly with a swipe of you know your
finger on your app you can have whatever
it is your heart desires to arrive at
your doorstep within 15 minutes so I
think that's that's certainly part of it
also the associations that we have with
these kinds of foods that maybe they
evoke um you know our childhoods in a
way like we reach for foods that remind
us of a more peaceful time in our lives
when the stakes were perhaps a bit lower
um so I think I think there's a lot of
different variables potentially at play
but um I think it's also really
important to not to not stigmatize I
mean and and pathologize ultimately
being depressed cuz depression and
stress are part for the course of Being
Human particularly today I mean we're
living in tumultuous times and
inevitably all of us is going to
encounter something in life that that
serves as a depressive stimulus I mean
I've been depressed in my life and it
wasn't attributable to my diet I've been
really depressed because of what was
going on for example in my family life
um with everything that that my mom went
through and and you know the the journey
that took me that has gotten me to this
place um and so it's it's important to
to not pathologize these kinds of normal
human emotions which I think is really
common especially in our world where
everything has become lately all about
optimization and the 1500 steps that you
have to do every morning before your
morning morning coffee to optimize your
day and to yeah we'll get back to
talking to Max in one minute but first I
need to tell you about mudwater mudwater
is a coffee alternative which tastes
like cacao and chai had a beautiful baby
together it is nearly winter time which
means you might want to hold on to your
hot drink but not have the caffeine
crash and Jitters that comes along with
coffee and mud water is the alternative
it's got four functional mushrooms Each
of which was chosen for a specific
purpose it's got cacao and chai for a
hint of caffeine and chocolate likee
taste liines man for Focus ceps to
promote Natural Energy and both chaga
and Rishi to help support a healthy
immune system plus it's Whole 30
approved 100% USDA organic kosher vegan
and gluten-free so if you are looking
for a delicious alternative to your
morning coffee this is where to start
right now you can save $20 plus get a
free sample of Crea and a free froth by
going to the link in the description
below or heading to Mud wt.com
slod wisdom that's mud wt.com
slod wisdom I brought this up with with
huberman yesterday I called it the Peril
of over optimization I have a friend who
is a worldclass DJ uh who messaged and
said dude loving the show blah blah blah
uh I have to say I'm starting to fall
out of love with DJing because I watch a
lot of good health communication
podcasts on the internet and every time
that I DJ and stay up till 4: in the
morning I feel guilt about not hitting
my morning waking Cadian Rhythm so his
love his his main passion in life he is
uh feeling that become tarnished because
he has guilt around the gap between his
potential optimized version and his
realized optimized version do you do you
see this as a trend among people well
yeah I mean certainly and I'm not an
expert in in disordered eating or eating
disorders but um that is one of the what
I've been able to glean from experts
that I've interacted with and and
ultimately PE people who've suffered
from disordered eating is that it's
important to remove the the moral the
morality from food
um I think if you have a healthy
relationship with food it's important to
have empirical definitions around food
like obviously you know a four-year-old
might be able to look at you know a a
certain food item a Bluffin Duffin A
Duffin yeah and um and identify that
that's maybe not as beneficial as uh you
know a stock of broccoli or an egg or a
piece of you know grass-fed grassfish
beef or something like that so you know
I think it's important to have to to to
m Ain definitions around food we live in
a time where seemingly it's impossible
to Define anything um and uh and I think
that's not helpful um but on the other
hand it is really important to remove
the shame that we feel around food
because at the end of the day one single
food one single meal isn't in any way
going to sway your biology in the
towards the direction of health or
disease it's about the dietary pattern
as a whole it's about we don't live in
the on average though right we don't
have the perspective what we have is
what is the lead measure of the thing
that I'm doing what is the story that I
tell myself about that oh my God I'm
such a piece of [__] this is exactly why
such and such a person left you this is
exactly why you're not realizing your
this is going to be the beginning of the
end you know it's very much a scarcity
fear mentality yeah I think it plays
into it yeah it's a big problem I've
actually heard this it referred to as
holistic derangement syndrome which is a
wow yeah let that settle in that is so
good holistic derangement syndrome yeah
this sort of obsession with over
optimization with understanding
that where was the is this grass
finished or is this grain finished can
we check with the was that actually
butter that the chef cooked it in
because that if there's a seed oil in
this um did I tell you about that study
uh that I learned in the expectation
effect David robson's thing about
glucose no dude uh gluten sorry so David
Robson the expectation effect everyone
should go and read his book everyone
should go and read your book genius
foods but everyone should also go and
read uh the expectation effect by David
Robson really great science writer from
the UK and um they bring people into the
lab to try and work out what's going on
with gluten intolerance that gluten
intolerance has nearly 10 xed over the
last 30 years I
think human biology hasn't changed that
much maybe the diet landscape has
changed a lot but like gluten gluten
right and the intolerance shouldn't have
changed that much they wanted to work
out whether it was due to in some part
this expectation effect yeah that people
were hearing a lot of demonization about
gluten uh so they bring people into the
lab set them down people that are in
there do and do not have biological
intolerances to gluten they've done the
tests they set everybody down they give
everybody the same meal they tell
everyone that it's got gluten in it's
got no glutenin within minutes people
are running to the toilet with diarrhea
they're breaking out in hives they've
got inflammation they've got tension
headaches no one ate gluten no one in
the entire room ate gluten and you had
all of the symptoms wow of gluten
intolerance manifesting it's wild it's
like a no sibo effect yep correct yep
yeah I
mean admit and I'm very much immersed in
the wellness world and I the I Love The
Wellness industry but I will concede
that you know it's it I think it has
done some damage um in the sense that
there's a lot of misinformation now
about what foods are beneficial what
foods are less so um and and I've I've
been I've drank the Kool-Aid at certain
points in my life where there was a time
when I thought Dairy was sort of like an
unclean food and uh that it wasn't ideal
from a health standpoint and now I mean
I'm I'm the biggest advocate of
consuming Dairy I think Dairy is a great
food if you if you tolerate it for
example you know there's like this idea
that clean eating is somehow dairy free
it's gluten- free it's free of all the
things right and um and I think it's
it's again really important to educate
with Nuance around these topics because
the the
people the proportion of our population
that is celiac is non-trivial it's 1 to
2% and a lot of people with
Celiac um or I'm sorry Celiac so you
know 1 to 2% is celiac and then there's
this spectrum of symptoms that people
will get that is attri that is thought
to be attributed to uh gluten called non
Celiac gluten sensitivity and that's
thought to be I mean that's a real thing
and that's widely underdiagnosed um so a
lot of people are do experience symptoms
um when they ingest gluten and gluten is
something that you know the the dose if
you want to consider it that and speak
in terms of uh gluten as something that
that is ultimately dosed is higher than
it's ever been I mean we now we breed
wheat to contain higher levels of gluten
because it provides a mouth feel that we
enjoy it's that gooey texture um and
also we're eating wheat I mean wheat is
one of these like foundational
ingredients to the ultra the the delu of
ultr processed foods that your average
person is now consuming and mass it's
wheat with breakfast lunch and dinner
and wheat snacks all in between so the
dose of gluten that your average person
is ingesting is massive
and I'm not saying that people need to
avoid gluten if they're not explicitly
sensitive to it um but it is a protein
that humans don't properly break down um
it does stimulate a protein in the gut
called zulin which basically leads to uh
increased permeability in sort of
increased
um in passage of uh ingredients from the
compounds from the Lumin of the gut in
through circulation through what are
typically tight junctions that are
closed oh this is like leaky gut yeah
right yeah I've learned so I had um I
went to Fountain life in Dallas and had
a full body MRI brain angiogram heart
angiogram uh a good microbiome analysis
dexa scan balance SC Everything full
full full full full works and uh they
came back and and they said you need to
take amra colostrum colostrum yeah uh
they said we need to just it's not bad
but you you could your gut could be less
leaky and uh that was the first time I
thought I didn't even know what the [__]
leaky gut was I didn't know if it was
due to to uh gluten or anything else but
uh yeah I think this like colostrum
products generally are going to be more
uh widely discussed um yeah so it seems
like overall gluten just something to
probably keep in the back of your mind
regardless of how well you think that
you tolerate it yeah and also um the
it's also the context in which in which
the gluten is being consumed I think
which also plays a role and is not
something that's being discussed enough
so we live in a time of widespread gut
dpos right again and not to keep harping
on this because I don't want to sound
like a broken record but your average
American's adult your average American
adult's diet is by and large Ultra
process one of the consequences of this
is that most people aren't consuming
adequate fiber now fiber is not an
essential nutrient but your average
American today I believe consume
somewhere between 5 and 15 grams of
fiber a day right so fiber is one of
these non-essential nutrients but it
seems to be associated with positive
Health outcomes it seems to be
associated with lower levels of
inflammation greater longevity and the
like and so there is a degree of
resilience that we should all be able to
cultivate with regard to our gut health
that we're simply not because again
we're just we're eating predominantly
junk Foods in the background with the
background of a low fiber diet and so
whereas you know we might we should have
the the resilience that it takes to be
able to ingest a protein like gluten um
and and be all right with it well we're
eating more gluten than ever before in
human history we're eating less fiber
than our ancestors likely ever consumed
it's estimated that our fiber that our
hunter gather ancestors were consuming
upwards of 150 grams of fiber a day
which is like you know orders of
magnitude more than we're consuming
today so it's like it's all it's the
it's the it's the dose
it's the compound it's the context
everything matters and so um can you exp
can you explain to me what's going on
with these new products that are low net
carb like some cereals have this some
bars have this what [__] is happening
on the back end what are net carbs and
is there any is there any sort of
Wizardry going on which is hiding
something in a in the deep dark annals
of the ingredient
yeah very likely um so a lot of these
you know net carbs really are mainly a
concern for people who are on a
ketogenic diet and um and I think it's
really important to lay out upfront a
lot of people are on the ketogenic diet
because they think it's the ultimate
diet for weight loss and if if you
prefer if a ketogenic diet is a diet
that you are most easily able to adhere
to then by all means have at it and I
also think I have to add all these sort
of nuances and disclaimers because
because #t science yes um and I think
it's important um the ketogenic diet I
think is a really important diet
particularly in the context of uh
neurological conditions epilepsy
primarily but also I think now we're
starting to see neurodegenerative age
related conditions like Alzheimer's
disease and Parkinson's disease it's a
very low carbohydrate diet and so net
carbohydrates come into play because
people want to be able to consume
processed foods um while still
allowing ketogenesis right still
allowing for Ketone Generation by eating
low carbs but I think one of the
problems with this is that a lot of
these low carb foods are so high in
calories that it's like you might as
well eat the original food like unless
you really have a medical reason for
being in ketosis um and so a lot of the
food manufacturers that produce these
keto Foods they achieve having lown net
carbs despite having a ton of calories
um by using either fibers which are
inaccessible to us we we're unable to uh
humans unable to break down fiber into
its into glucose so it's it passes
through the small intestine basically uh
unadulterated and then it becomes food
essentially like a food substrate for
the bacteria that live in our large
intestines um and this is true for
fibers found in Whole Foods what remains
to be seen is whether or not these
extracts that are now being used as
sweeteners in these ketogenic products
function the same way um I think the
jury is still out the FDA last I recall
is
investigating uh ingredients like
tapioca fiber syrup and all those kind
ch root fiber to see if they actually um
do pass through the small intestine un
assimilated undigested which would allow
them to maintain that they are in fact
fibers but I've seen people cuz now
there is this sort of trend of people
wearing non diabetics wearing continuous
glucose monitors and I've heard reports
from people that follow me that they'll
eat a lot of these keto products that
allegedly have very few net carbs and
regardless they still see uh a pretty
significant spike in their blood sugar
which would suggest that they these
fibers are not acting like true fibers
yeah um so at the end of the day I think
you know and this is again another area
where where I've evolved I used to by
default opt for these fake foods with
the fake fibers that have low net carbs
but now I think you know ultimately like
a cookie is a cookie right like ice
cream is ice cream so if you're going to
reach for one of these foods and and you
don't have a medical necessity for being
in therapeutic ketosis you might as well
offer the real thing you know and and be
cognizant of the overall calorie count
of these products because at the end of
the day I mean they're junk Foods what
do you think of this trend of young
girls avoiding eating meat and protein
and instead replacing it with salads and
smoothies and just ruffage for days
horrible yeah so I'm a I'm a huge
advocate an Unapologetic advocate for
omniv I think it's you know there's this
push at the public health scale to um
towards plant-based diets and and and
also online you see obviously you know a
lot of women in particular uh have
embraced these diets I think in part and
I'm not obviously I'm not a woman I
don't know what their lived experience
is like but what I've been able to glean
from my friends and other experts in
this in this area is that a lot of women
avoid meat and protein and they opt
instead for salads because they think
that it's going to make them smaller to
eat that way to eat like a rabbit um and
this is a big problem you know a lot of
women today have body image issues I
think perpetuated at least part by
social media the fact that you see
people men and women that have
phenomenal bodies that are you know
usually augmented male I I just to
interject that male body DM morphia will
overtake women's within the next two
decades wow it's on track to overtake it
yeah it's crazy it's crazy I mean the
pressure to look a certain way now on
social media I mean they're augmented
they're augmented like behind the camera
right and then
post and then post being posted yeah um
so it's yeah it's it's really
problematic and so you know the the
pressures I mean women have always faced
body pressure right I think this is fair
a fairly new arena for the fellas but um
yeah women I think have always wanted to
particularly since the 90s like appear
smaller um there's this idea that eating
meat I think is masculine that it's
going to make that it's going to make
you bigger that it's harder to digest I
mean steak should actually be steak is
is incredibly should be very easy to
digest the problem is a lot of people
that are on low meat diets they're
depriving their bodies of the raw
materials required to create stomach
acid so you know if you're on a low meat
diet then you decide you know once in a
blue moon to have a piece of red meat
well you might be low in the minerals
required to generate adequate stomach
acid to allow you to properly digest
that food and you will mistake the
discomfort after eating that meat as oh
this is what meat eating meat is like
for all people right you've conditioned
your stomach to not be able to do the
thing so what is the result for girls in
the way that they look and feel by being
ruffage pilled well I mean ruffage is
like I'm the biggest advocate of eating
dark leafy greens I think dark leafy
greens are an incredible food but if
that's all you're eating you know they
are hard to digest I mean for example
when you know anybody's who's ever had
like a uh like a procedure on the large
bowel they're told you're told prior to
the procedure to go on a low residue
diet a low residue diet is a low fiber
diet red meat is is is low residue
basically like the residue are the is
the indigestible material that makes its
way down to the large intestine that
gets then fermented and create can can
potentially create particularly if
you're unadapted to it symptoms like gas
and bloating and things like that um
steak should be one of the one of the
easiest foods to digest um and uh and so
on the other hand you have women and
people in general not just not not to
single out women but people that you
know they base their whole diets around
cellulose you know like greens and and
indigestible plant material and they
wonder why they're walking around
bloated all the time and they're also
you know studies show that people who
are on vegetarian and vegan diets they
tend to eat less protein we know that
protein is really important for a number
of reasons it's
satiating uh at the very least but it
also helps to preserve and grow you know
your muscle tissue it's important for
providing you know amino acids which are
the backbones to your
neurotransmitters um so yeah there is I
think a consequence to yeah to basing
your diet around just
like rabbit food well this it seems to
go hand inand with a trend that at least
as far as I can tell is kind of falling
away now which is like the thigh gap
Obsession uh very willowy kind of the
you know the London Look model kind
super sort of stringy thing but even
within that there's a softness to the
body type right of people both guys and
girls that do that because it again
thankfully it's falling away and the
pivot from thin SPO to fit SPO I think
has actually largely been really good in
that encouraging uh resistance training
encouraging higher calorie meals
prioritization of protein more focus on
training uh even like a bit of g-lux
theor thing coming in like let's try and
create a calorie deficit through both
calorie restriction but also through
training increase so know both sides of
the the Kao equation
um but you see and I see it as well man
like I see a lot of the girls that um we
used to work with at our events company
you're 18 19 20 years old and you're
dancing for our events company and you
want to look good in your dancers outfit
on stage or whatever and the girls that
would push a little bit harder on
calories and train would have a
different kind of uh Physique in the way
that it presented like the skin seemed a
little bit sort of like uh thinner and
Tighter and more translucent and you
could see the shape of their bodies
underneath it as opposed to someone
that's just dieting themselves into the
ground 1 1300 1100 calories a day in a
desperate attempt to try and get down
and there's like a there's like softness
there's like there's a yeah there's a
softness despite there not being much
there what is there still feels like
that yeah yeah I mean that is a recipe
when you zoom out and you extrapolate
out 10 20 30 40 years down the road I
mean that that's a recipe for sarcopenia
at the very least what's that it's um
accelerated muscle wasting um and just a
a lack of strength as one Ages which is
fairly common these days the worst is
sarcopenic obesity so it's like excess
at osity along with being under mused oh
yeah uh Dr Gabrielle lion was on the
show this week talking about her muscle
centered medicine great and uh yeah this
is a big a big movement I think this is
again so much sort of convergent trend
happening here we've got maybe the sign
side coming in we've got that but yeah
dude I mean it's super yeah it's and and
not not even to mention the the
important minerals and micronutrients
that women are you know potentially
missing out on that are particularly
important to the pre-menopausal woman so
you know for example heem iron which is
found primarily in red meat you know red
meat is the ultimate iron supplement and
women who are premenstrual I mean
there's like anemia is super common iron
deficiency anemia is super common today
and well women lose quite a bit of iron
once every 28 days there you go yeah
yeah so I mean we're going to get it's
we're going to get red flag for
mansplaining I'm sure by
somebody don't tell me how my periods
work I don't even like them no but um no
you're 100% right though I think like
you know they women and the fitbo thing
I think is great you know in the sense
that it's gotten more women sort of
aware to the benefits of resistance
training the and and you know a lot of
us have worked really hard to dispel the
myth that resistance training is going
to lead to a bigger bulkier body it
doesn't you know women have testosterone
but on Tenth of testosterone of men and
it's really important for you know for
libido it's important for well-being
body composition but it's not going to
make you it's not going to lead to you
ending up looking like Chris Bumstead
right bro I said this yesterday to
hberman do you realize how desperately
hard I've tried for a decade and a half
to become bulky like I work most moments
of every day to put things into my body
and do stuff to my body to become bulky
like you're not accidentally going to do
a couple of supern bicep curls and then
look like SE buum exactly you know it's
not going to creep up on you and if it
does please tell me the protocol that
you were doing same we'll get back to
talking to Max in one minute but first I
need to tell you about
element thank you element contains a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium po potassium and magnesium with
no junk no coloring no artificial
ingredients or any other BS it's how
I've started my morning for over 3 years
now and it helps to regulate my appetite
curb cravings and optimize my brain
health first thing in the morning you
don't need to have coffee your caffeine
receptors the adenosine system isn't
even active for the first 90 minutes of
the day but your adrenal system is and
salt acts on your adrenal system this
orange flavor is the best way that you
could start your morning why I continue
to go on about it because I use it and I
love it for myself best first of all
there is a no BS no questions asked
refund policy where you can buy it 100%
risk-free And if you do not love it for
any reason they will give you your money
back and you don't even need to return
the box right now you can get a free
sample pack of all eight flavors with
your first box by going to the link in
the description below or heading to
drink LM nt.com slod wisdom that's drink
LM nt.com
slod
wisdom you posted a study talking about
two minutes of exercise a day reduces
cancer risk by up to
20% yeah I mean all this kind of
research comes out all the time and it's
super interesting and it's not to say
that all you need to do is 2 minutes a
day of exercise right that's not the
point of the study but what it I think
the the drive home message is that we're
not um impotent to uh to these kinds of
conditions which now seem to be so
rampant today right like cancer um I've
had a number of cancer experts on my
podcast uh
as of late actually Thomas sa freed you
know is a wonderful uh expert in this
field also Joe zandell is a good friend
of mine who is another cancer expert and
the the resounding advice that you get
from both of these experts is that uh
exercise really is medicine I mean it's
super super important in terms of
reducing inflammation in terms of
building your robustness your
resilience um yeah it's crucial and so I
don't know if two minutes a day is
necessarily going to suffice but um but
yeah I mean again like today the milu of
the western not just diet but lifestyle
were largely sedentary like Leisure Time
physical activity as is at an all-time
low and we're starting to see increased
rates of cancer now among younger people
there was another study that made major
headlines recently that found that rates
of cancer and particularly malignant
cancer
among uh cohort that typically you
wouldn't see much of this type of cancer
in is now increasing right rates of
breast cancer have I think like doubled
since just 50 years ago so I mean
there's something in the modern
world you know one one variable Myriad
variables that have become essentially
toxic and I think one of the variables
that has that is essentially toxen is
the fact that we are now that so many of
us are sedentary um it's a big problem
and it doesn't take a ton of exercise
like you don't have to be like a gym bro
like you or I to reap the benefits of
exercise
but I think it is super important to
have an exercise routine and
particularly one that prioritizes
resistance training I mean this idea
that you can just be active like a lot
of older adults I think are told to just
be active right which I think is
typically um taken as just walk you know
just like walk as much as you can and
walking is great walking is great no
matter where on the age Spectrum you are
but I think resistance training has long
been sort of thought to be this pastime
of Bros
and uh and I think that's a big problem
I mean we're proudly proudly a pastime
of bros there you go dude the uh 10
minute to 15 minute walk after eating
yeah for me is about as close of a like
superpower as I've been able to find and
I first got taught this from Stu Mill
like four years ago back pain expert
flew up to Canada to see him and he was
doing it primarily for U the relieving
of back pain and what he was doing was
you need to walk um small doses
frequently and a good cue for that is
when you have something to eat you're
going to eat at least multiple times per
day go for the walk afterward and he
mentioned at the time there's some
benefits too Downstream and maybe
mentioned a couple of bits and just The
Last Five Years Mark Bell and Stan
effing right with the I think he calls
it the 10-minute walk but 15 seems
better and if you're eating you know if
you get one in on a morning to get some
sunlight in the eyes because you're
hubman pilled and then you have three
meals a day and you do if you can get a
nice 10 to 15 minute loop from wherever
you are that's also your 10,000 steps
sorted that's also going to improve your
insulin sensitivity that's also going to
help you to blow off a little bit of
that Spike that you get post eating it's
going to the U muscles like the Contra
lateral muscles that run across the
stomach it actually helps to move food
at least it does for me if I have a big
meal I actually feel like the food is
able to move through my digestion more
easily if I go for a walk afterward the
two nights that we've been here we've
had big dinners both times Cheesecake
Factory in Buffalo Wild Wings because
because I I I am a child um and both
times we've been for a walk for 15
minutes afterward and I can go to sleep
more easily on an evening time it's just
it's a a real phenomenal hack and I
think that struggling to get your walks
in maybe you're concerned about what's
happening with insulin maybe you want to
get a little bit more time outside in
nature and be away from your phone it's
I love these habits where you can stack
a bunch of different things on top of
them I get some more time outside I'm
going to get some more sunlight I'm
going to get some more fresh air I'm not
going to be on my phont blah blah blah I
it's a real 10 minute walk 15 minute
walk after eating fing I'm all in yeah I
mean walking moves there are so many
benefits to walking but I mean you have
fluids in your body that don't have
their own heart and so for example
lymphatic flow right like walking helps
to promote that which is involved in
which plays a role in digestion we know
that just a short walk postmeal reduces
that postprandial blood sugar Spike
which is thought to be beneficial
particularly if you have glucose
tolerance issues right we know that
walking helps to remove fat in the blood
um super important we see that there's
an association particularly um in
younger people between around 7,000 to
10,000 steps a day and lower risk of all
cause mortality and then about 10,000 I
think to 12,000 steps among older people
um that 10 the whole 10,000 steps a day
thing is a little bit BS but there
actually was a meta Anis that came out
fairly recently I think over the past
year that found that it it there is
actually a Zone that's not too far off
from that 10,000 step Mark that seems to
be associated with you need to pick a
number you know what I mean exactly yeah
it depends on how quickly you walk I
suppose there was a New York Post
article titled I'm raising my child
vegan it's not as simple as you think
and you replied and said child abuse yes
what's going on yeah I mean I I think
you know we are biologically adapted to
be
omnivores and um we know that the
neonate relies on the mother deriving
adequate nutrition from her food and
there are the if you look at the most
nutrient-dense Foods available to your
average person today there's literally a
paper people can look it up published by
Beal et al two to three years ago that
ranked all the most nutrient-dense Foods
particularly by nutrients of concern so
nutrients that people tend to underc
consume today zinc vitamin B12 and
things like that and animal products
were took all the top spots with the
exception being uh dark leafy greens
which are thought to be very very
nutrient-dense because they're so
calorie sparse and they can they're a
good source of vitamin C and folate and
calcium and the like but animal products
are our most nutrient-dense foods and
when you're a pregnant woman you are
eating for two so you know we already
see that pregnant women tend to underc
consume protein um you know consumption
of choline which is a really important
uh nutrient for I mean you put choline
right City choline in your in your
neurotropic beverage right here like
super important for brain development
for cognitive function um vitamin B12
crucially important there's so many DHA
fat right like pre-formed DHA fat which
is found exclusively in animal products
you can consume Omega-3s from Plants but
humans are very in efficient at
converting it to its usable forms in the
body and so I mean that's from the
standpoint of pregnancy like if I
were in at the stage in my life where I
were looking to procreate I would want
to procreate with an omnivorous woman
and it's like saying something like that
is controversial today but it shouldn't
be Max lug wants to procreate with an
omnivorous woman ladies you have this is
the sign that you have been looking for
it's the bad signal yeah um yeah so I
mean that's that's super important I
think like you with regards to
plant-based diets you can Cobble
together a diet that leads to better
biomarkers and and ultimately look a
plant-based diet compared to the
standard American diet is going to be a
healthier choice right um You can Cobble
together a diet that you know with the
use of protein supplements perhaps uh
can can can afford you a fantastic body
composition but I think from the
standpoint of pregnancy and ultimately
development and and childhood
development I think it's really
important to um yeah to allow your child
who's inevitably going to be a picky
eater as it is because that's inevitably
children because they're a child yeah I
think it's really important to not cross
off the list because of some silly
ideology one of the most nutrient-dense
the most nutrient-dense category of
foods available to your average human
what do you do you have any idea what
will happen to a child who is lacking in
many of the sort of things that a vegan
diet would cause there to be a bereft uh
yeah I mean look stunted development um
failure to thrive I mean I you know I
just think it's I think
you're it's essentially sometimes
referred to as nutritionism this idea
that humans with all of our hubris can
distill food into its constituent
nutrients and then replicate food in a
way with with processed Alternatives I
mean if you take something like the
product soilent it's a perfect example
of that right it's like what happens
when Silicon Valley people try to create
food they break down a food into its
constituent nutrients right the data
that makes a food food according to them
this is the code of food yeah this is
the code of food and and we have this
Ultra processed ultimately crap product
but here it is right like you're not
going to develop a deficiency disease if
this is all you consume every day and so
that's like nutritionism and I think it
fails time and time again because we
didn't evolve with these nutrients in
isolation we've evolved with food and we
have a handful of nut nutrients that we
know are essential but that list of
what's essential what's conditionally
essential and what's non-essential is
changing all the time as it should and
Foods don't just contain these single
nutrients in isolation right like an
orange isn't just doesn't just provide
vitamin C right there are countless
other innumerable like nutrients that we
have yet to even name likely compounds
in you know in an orange that might have
an Entourage effect that might increase
the absorption the bioavailability of
the vitamin C for example and the RDA
for vitamin C is set to avoid scurvy at
the population level right but that
doesn't mean that we're all consuming
adequate levels of vitamin C to promote
optimal collagen synthesis for example
which we know vitamin C is involved in
so you know foods have all of these
different nutrients and you take a food
like red meat right like red meat has uh
it contains vitamin B12 which somebody
on a plant-based diet might say well
that's the one essential nutrient you
can't get on a plant-based diet I can
just take a vitamin B12 supplement but
what about the constellation of
nutrients that that vitamin B12 comes
with right like the heem iron the
carnitine the carnosine the creatine
which we know is really important from a
standpoint of muscular Health right um
and so you're just depriving uh a baby
of you know of all of those different
nutrients and look the standard American
diet isn't isn't great either like you
have a lot of children these days that
have early onset hypertension early on
set type two diabetes so I'm not saying
that the alternative is St is the
standard American diet but I think that
you can
that yeah that like you can the ultimate
optimal diet
for certainly for a developing human but
also for an adult is a diet that
incorporates both animal products and
and uh plant products it's interesting
to think that the child abuse thing is
uh like a really interesting frame of it
because you are locking into this
neonatal human a kind of develop vment
that they didn't choose yeah that they
had no Val in saying yes or no to and I
guess you know largely until the age of
probably 14 or 15 when they can use the
stove themselves and actually fully
understand what's going into them you
know even throughout preschool so on and
so forth you're still largely doing that
but when it's you have to what you eat
is what your child eats in some regard
uh it's wild I have a friend Alex who
was a uh vegan
uh philosopher for a good while he was
ethically convinced by Peter singer's
work uh animal Liberation which I still
think from an ethical
perspective I I think that we're going
to look back on what we do now with much
of animal farming and think of it as
abhorent I think you're going to look
back and see it as not quite sort of
Holocaust but in that sort of Realm oh
my God we had sentient animals and we
did this to them
right he became completely vegan pilled
he became an advocate he is an
unbelievably effective debater at
everything but particularly for veganism
and he found after going vegan that
making a commitment making a sacrifice
uh to the philosophy that he the ethics
that he'd been convinced by he found
that he was suffering uh his body and
his mental health had both taken a a
pretty big like an increasingly big hit
from this and he he posted the day that
he became unconvinced that he could meet
an adequately balanced vegan diet he
immediately felt like it was his um he
was compelled to tell his audience
because again he came here he got here
from being ethical and being truthful
and high integrity with his ethics and
then as soon as those had changed he
decided to put a post out and I said
don't do this you are opening yourself
up to a tone of criticism wait until you
can do the video and he said well yeah
but what if someone sees me eating
salmon on a train or something in the UK
like I'm not going to feel in line so
again he was like hoisted by his own
ethics again he got absolutely pillared
by the internet for doing it we you know
you were supposed to you said that you
understood and a blah blah blah and then
he did a video talking through how he
was struggling to be able to eat a
completely balanced uh sufficiently
robust plant-based diet and again people
had massive problems and now I think
he's probably one year hence is wow
mental health is way better his uh
Pursuit that he goes after in life is
flourishing his energy levels have
improved all of this stuff again this
isn't for me to say look vegans you're
condemning yourself to a life of low
energy misery but there are people out
there for whom the limitations that you
place on yourself by going on a vegan
diet make getting a balanced diet so
much more difficult again and if you're
a
24-year-old YouTu YouTuber and writer
who maybe still needs to do a bit of
growing
up you life's hard enough as it like you
you just trying to get up before midday
do you know what I mean like you're
trying not to go out and party with your
friends too much you're trying to like
learn what productivity is and how do I
do my taxes and like the Rel I've got a
relationship or I'm not in whatever you
know these are additional uh levels of
complexity and difficulty that I don't
think you need to add into your life uh
and yeah you know this is very very much
kind of Fallen by the way side now and
Alex is is out on the other side but uh
I really respected him for what for what
he decided to do with that that he said
look I've given this a crack I'm still
ethically convinced by veganism but
physiologically I don't think that I can
do I don't think I can commit to this
and yeah out the other side of that he's
now just he's he's crushing it he's
absolutely crushing it also I mean as
you referenced when you're younger you
have more resilience like a younger body
is a more resilient body I mean think
about all the late nights all the I mean
for me like when I was in college I used
to drink a lot I don't have a problem
with alcohol but like I would I would
consume alcohol I would do other things
like and your body rebounds really fast
when you're young right because you have
rubber and Magic yeah we're High we're a
highly adaptable species that's one of
the the amazing things about being a
human being right but as you get older I
mean I'm telling you I have a lot of
friends that are in middle age and that
are still Clinging On to this idea of a
of a plant-based diet being optimal and
again they look sarcopenic you know I
mean you can find vegan bodybuilders
like those outliers exist you know some
of them are augmented don't necessarily
cop to it all good not judging or maybe
judging a little bit because they
attribute they tend to attribute their
gains to being vegan not to the
exogenous testosterone there you go
again you can Cobble like we know that
plant protein at this point and animal
protein when you consume enough protein
the muscle gains are comparable so that
you know there's no issue there but for
most again for most people for most
people that are not obsessive Fitness
junkies um it's a big problem they tend
to underc consume protein and um and as
you get older you become anabolic
resistant I'm sure Gabrielle lion talked
about this you become resistant to
locing so the little Lucine that you're
getting on a plant-based diet is
becoming even less effective you know as
you get older and whether it's
andropause or menopause you're fighting
a losing battle with regard to your
hormones ultimately unless you're on you
know HRT and so it's a it's a huge
problem but younger people you know
maybe they adopt a vegan diet for a few
months or years and they feel good right
the body has stores of certain vitamins
they're again more resilient they're
more adaptable and so it's fine but yeah
it's not uncommon these days to see
whether they're influencers on YouTube
or on Instagram that are that were
previously vegan either covertly eating
animal products which I've heard happens
like they're doing it covertly or they
they make the switch right I'm eating
steak wrapped in spinach and no one one
can see what's inside of this dude it
happens it happens and with regard to
mental health specifically there are so
many nutrients and animal products that
are just required by the human brain I
mean we attribute the development of the
human brain to access to the nutrients
found in animal products right so this
idea again it's just hubris right it's
hubris and I hate the p word but I'll
use it privilege that we think that we
can Cobble together a diet that mimics
our the diet the kind of diet that we
Evol we know better than nature yeah we
don't need to use no no no no we don't
need to grow it and pull it out of the
ground no no we can do it from code from
first we'll Matrix our way into creating
a diet yeah it's it's it's wild man talk
to me about this new film that you just
finished you very kindly sent me a link
so that I could get first access to it
last night yeah so it's called Little
empty boxes and um people can watch a
trailer at little empty boxes.com and
it's the first ever dementia prevention
film and it's about 75%
uh narrative 25% science but the
narrative follows my mom and why I do
anything that it is that I do is because
my mom got very sick at a very young age
she developed a rare form of dementia
called Louis body dementia and um I mean
this was 10 years ago that I began
working on the project and back then I
didn't know anything about Alzheimer's
disease or Parkinson's disease or
anything like that I was just a scared
son looking to do whatever was possible
to help his
um in a time of immense trauma and
tragedy um and so the film kind of is
like a time capsule it documents
everything that my mom went through the
The Descent into dementia it's really
really difficult um and it's been a
labor of love and ultimately the film is
is a tribute to my mom but it's also a
tribute to the science so you know as
much as I think you know we get in into
debates on the inter interpretations of
science particularly in the field of
nutrition which is you know where my
passion happens to lie I'm a huge fan of
Science and I think it's incredible and
so the film I created to be a tribute to
this this growing field of acceptance
known as dementia prevention whereas 10
years prior you couldn't mention
dementia and prevention within the same
sentence you'd get like produce thrown
at you because dementia for a long time
was thought to be an unpreventable
condition like even the Alzheimer's
Association was one of the largest
nonprofit organizations you know for
years and years and years de you know
would drive home this fear-based talking
point I think primarily to raise funding
that dementia is the only Alzheimer's
disease is the only condition that can't
be prevented treated or slowed and we
know now I mean thanks to incredible
research
that that the potential for prevention
is High and um and so yeah so the
documentary is like a a testament to
that and it offers some I think really
action tips and it's in very it's in
many ways the prequel to my work you
know cuz since since embarking on this
production process I've written my books
I've launched my podcast and you know
I'm grateful that many people um and and
mind blown actually that many people
consider me an expert in this field um
because I'm ultimately a lay person like
I'm somebody who really began just to be
able to you know with the intent of
gleaning answers for their mom um but
I've learned a ton
uh you
know over the course of my journey but
the documentary really is to is to
document what it's like being a
caregiver um for somebody with dementia
and to show people what it what it
really is like and how valuable and
important prevention is because dementia
begins in the brain decades before the
first symptom and this is something that
is when you look at the science coming
out about dementia
Alzheimer's um based Therapeutics
Alzheimer's drug trials have a 99.6%
fail rate they're just dismally
effective um if at all and this is
because this is a condition that
manifests in the brain over a span of
years if not decades so it's really
important I think for people like
younger people Millennials you know
you're you're the oldest Millennial is
now in their 40s and so the time is like
there's no better time than right now to
start thinking about your brain with
your choices because I mean once it goes
it goes what are the big myths and
realizations about neuro degeneration
dementia Parkinson stuff like that like
what were the the big
unpredicted insights that you got on
this journey well I think for one people
think that it's genetic um you have
genetic risk factors so the apoe4 alil
is the most well-defined of the
Alzheimer's uh and ultimately
neurodegenerative risk factors is that
the one that Chris Hemsworth realized
that he had yeah so he realized that he
was a homozygous carrier he was an APO
44 which increases your risk around 12
to 14 fold um 12 to 14 fold yeah wow how
low is this cuz it could be 12 to 14
fold from 0.1 to 0.12 or whatever yeah
that's an interesting question um we
always got to consider the base right
yeah like the absolute risk today about
5 million people in the US have
Alzheimer's disease so 5 million out of
300 million it's just fairly you know
low proportion but um but that number is
set to explode in the coming years um
the rates of Alzheimer's are increasing
and I think it's clear that we have what
are called modifiable risk factors and
the rates of those modifiable risk
factors are also increasing so for
example if you have obesity your risk
for Alzheimer's disease increases if you
have type two diabetes your risk for
Alzheimer's disease increas is between
two and fourfold if you have
hypertension today one and two adults
have hypertension that increases your
risk stacked on top of each other yeah
exactly so we're seeing increasing rates
of all of those um those uh conditions
and so that's what is that doing it's
not it's not doing our brain health our
Collective brain health any favors and
so that's one of them that it's genetic
you know the vast majority of of
dementia cases are attributable to an
interaction between the genetic risk
factors that you may carry and the
environment but also with regard to
genes which are non-modifiable risk
factor of course there's what the
concept of polygenic risk so you might
have genes that we have yet to elucidate
that are canceling out the risk of of
said risk genes 2 to 3% of Alzheimer's
cases are attributable to a a
deterministic gene called early onset
familial again tiny minority but as
recently as 2020 the lanet Comm
Commission on dementia pointed out that
at least 40% of Alzheimer's cases are
preventable and I think that's a gross
underestimate because in that paper it
didn't even talk about all the it didn't
even talk about exposure to
environmental toxicants or drugs um we
know that people who routinely take
anti-cholinergic drugs are at higher
risk of developing dementia and that
wasn't even elucidated in the paper so
um I think the vast majority of of uh
Alzheimer's cases are potentially
preventable and I don't claim to have
all the answers we we don't um certainly
but uh but yeah there is a lot that
people can do if you were to I always
like inverting stuff like this if you
were to try and Design a lifestyle for
someone that would onset their
predisposition or lack of neurod
degeneration as quickly as possible what
would you prescribe that person if you
were like you're some Demon from hell
and you want to try and make this
person's brain uh degenerate toward some
dementia parkinsonian style thing what
would what would you get that person to
do yeah they I would uh deprive them of
sleep we know sleep is crucially
important um sleep is when your brain is
actually clean cleaning itself of
proteins that are associated with the
condition so Amoy beta tow protein we
see increases in cerebros spinal fluid
on just one night of shorten sleep so I
would deprive them of sleep sleep is
really important with regard to brain
health it's it's important with regard
to mental health but it's very important
with with regard to how your brain
actually functions um so there's that
chronic stress is a killer we know that
chronically elevated cortisol leads to
shrinkage of the hippocampus which is
the most vulnerable structure of the
brain the first one of the first
structures of the brain to to be uh to
be affected by Alzheimer's disease it's
where you know it's the memory
processing center of the brain we know
that chronically elevated cortisol which
is rought by chronically elevated levels
of stress um is not good from a brain
health standpoint it also creates an
inflammatory effect in the
body um I would from a dietary
standpoint I would give a person
exclusively Ultra processed foods to
consume um we know that these kinds of
foods not only create inflammation in
the body but they drive osity or obesity
we know that they create uh the
phenomena of insulin resistance and we
know that insulin resistance is not good
from a brain health standpoint um
actually in Alzheimer's disease you see
a reduction in the brain's ability to
generate uh energy from glucose and in
the Alzheimer's affected brain the that
ability is diminished by about 50% and
the brain is a ravenous energy consumer
and so I mean that's just like lights
out for the brain right you can imagine
how detrimental that might be well we
see that the level of glucose metabolism
in the Alzheimer's affected brain is
actually very strongly correlated with
the degree of insulin resistance in the
body so you want to make sure that
you're as insulin sensitive as possible
and so one way to do that is by you know
optimizing for protein in your diet
we're starting to see all this Research
Now come out about the value of of
dietary protein minimizing your
consumption of ultra processed foods
make sure that you're at a healthy
weight and then finally this kind of um
funnels into the lifestyle
recommendation which would be if you
want to develop dementia as soon as
possible make sure that you are highly
sedentary and that you never exercise
the brain thrives at top of body that's
you know moving and that's exercising
and there's tons of evidence now on this
both as a preventative strategy and also
as a way to slow down the progression of
neurod
degeneration so making sure that you're
that you're resistance training and I
mean I can't underscore that enough
resistance training is super super
important we're seeing a correlation now
Andy Galpin is uh you know he's one of
these guys who's who's become fairly
prominent in our space just published a
paper looking at whole body strength and
cognitive function and this is just this
is one of many papers right that has
come out showing us the link between uh
robustness strength and it's not even
necessarily muscle mass right so it's
like not we don't all have to look like
seum right after all or you um to to
procure better Brains it's just about
being strong in body and resistance
training is the best way to to to do
that and optimizing for protein again
and so yeah I mean right there okay so
if that if that's the the the Demon's
prescription of what you would do if you
wanted to Onset it when it comes to
strategies and tactics that people can
lean on um a food type any
supplementation any other sort of
Lifestyle interventions what is there on
the on the sort of positive side yeah
so the it's it's very um the the diet
dementia recommendations
are all the evidence
is I don't want to say weak but we have
the the best sort of idea for what a
brain healthful diet might look like is
referred to as the Mind diet which is
the sort of diet that's been cobbled
together by an epidemiologist of
observational research that combines the
some of the attributes of the
Mediterranean diet with some of the
attributes of the DASH diet which is the
dietary approach to stop hypertension
because again hypertension is one of
these important modifiable risk factors
hypertension is high blood pressure so
it's a Mediterranean diet combined with
the DASH diet with a sprinkling of you
know foods that we've found specifically
play a brain beneficial role for example
blueberries right the Mind diet only
recommends uh in terms of fruit the only
fruit that the mind diet recommends
makes a recommendation for our
blueberries right pretty dialed as a
fruit I know that we want but it's
blueberries
are blueberries pineapples bananas AAA
rated fruits for me no blueberries are
great but I think that's where the
limitations of that kind of like dietary
recommendation comes in because avocados
are a fruit and if I had to if I had to
pick a fruit that I thought was
potentially most beneficial to the brain
I think avoc are actually probably the
most beneficial fruit to the brain
because they have the highest proportion
of fat protecting specifically fat
protecting antioxidants of any fruit or
vegetable which is of particular
relevance to the brain because the brain
is made of fat and not just any type of
fat but the brain is comprised primarily
of polyunsaturated fatty acids which are
especially damag prone they're the most
chemically unstable of fatty acids you
have your polyunsaturated fatty acids
your monounsaturated fatty acids and
your saturated fatty acids saturated
fatty acids being the most chemically
stable but your brain is comprised
primarily of polyunsaturated fats DHA
fat doosa hexenoic acid and arachadonic
acid um and so we need to protect these
fats right the brain is a crucible for
oxidative stress because it's
metabolizing 25% of Every Breath You
Take in a container the size of a
grapefruit so it makes up 2 to 3% of
your body's Mass yet it accounts for 25%
of your body's oxygen metabolism so
again Crucible for oxidative stress what
can help protect the brain under those
circumstances
antioxidants and so fat protecting
antioxidants really important I think
avocados are again one of the best brain
foods that you can consume they're also
rich in compounds like lutein and
zanthin which we know are really
supportive of cognitive function
wonderful source of potassium which we
know is uh really important for
cardiovascular health so you know the
Mind diet is a great starting place but
there was just a randomized control
trial that put the Mind diet compared
the the the Mind diet in a atrisk
population I believe um and found no
benefit over just a calorie deficit in
an older adult population so you see
what I'm saying so nutrition science is
incredibly weak and that's where you
have to you can't be you can't be prone
to scientism which is like this you know
adherence to Scientific data as if it is
religious Doctrine that's just not not
how it works right like nutrition
science is harder to study than drug
than drugs and yet it's much less well
funded so a Whole Food's diet is my
prescription it's a diet that
incorporates both animal products I
think grass-fed grassfish red meat is a
brain health superfood along with
avocados and dark leafy greens and um
shellfish I think are incredible um
legumes I think are incredible but yeah
I I think omn 100% And avoiding the ultr
processed food is processed foods as
best as best you can foods with refined
grains foods with added sugar foods with
refined bleach and deodorized Seed oils
I think that's the the way to go I
noticed that at no point in this
preventable neurod degeneration
conversation have you mentioned doing
sodoku yeah or or brain training or uh
crossword puzzles or or anything like
that is there a is this just so low down
on the the sprinkling on the cake and
everything else is the foundation or is
there something in the brain training
wise no it's a that's a good question I
think um keeping keeping active and
staying socially engaged and doing
things that require that draw on a
complex array of cognitive processes I
think that's very helpful and there is
evidence that that can help build What's
called the cognitive Reserve which is
super important so the cognitive Reserve
basically stipulates that the more you
have to lose the better off you're going
to be it's a form of cognitive
resilience that you're building um
sodoku things that are like really kind
of more like on the simplistic side like
crossw word puzzles and S speak for
yourself man I can't do sud yeah I mean
I don't remember the last time I've even
attempted but um it's essentially like
they're better than nothing right better
than nothing but uh but they're too
simplistic to really have what's
sometimes referred to as a spillover
effect where they can actually improve
other cognitive domains whereas engaging
more in real life is actually the best
way to to to build that cognitive
Reserve like engaging in real life
learning a new instrument perhaps
learning a language learning a new skill
those are all super important because
they're more complex than just sitting
down and you know playing a numbers game
yeah I uh I had Roy
balme uh and Robin Dunbar on the show uh
within the last year and Dunbar was
talking about how the most
computationally difficult thing that
humans have to do is tracking the social
intricacies of all of their friend
groups right I know Max and I know John
and I know that Max and John used to be
friends but they're not anymore and the
reason because of that is because of
Fred uh and Fred is friends with Dan but
Dan and Max they don't get on because of
this thing from before like his argument
is that although we look at the brain
and we use the brain largely for this
sort of beautiful cerebral consider the
nature of the universe man am I really
enacting my Logos forward like all of
that stuff but what it was there for was
to track between 50 and 150
intersecting hierarchy based
relationships and you know from a
computational perspective I think again
that's one of the reasons why
relationships are it's like the
10-minute walk right it's not just the
walk it's not just the insulin it's
outside being single biggest determinant
of how long you're going to live is the
quality of your your relationships it's
more than smoking it's more than diet
it's more than your weight you know and
if you can manage to use uh hopefully
not a drama ridden set of friendships
but if you can use all of the different
friendships you have as a push as a a
a that is part of your um cognitive
horsepower uh backup I think that that's
a really good way to do it 100% yeah
loneliness is a toxin on par with with
ALC alcoholism these days um is what
this what we're starting to see um and
that I think you referenced to Harvard
the Harvard study is like the longest
running study on human happiness 0 years
longitudinal yeah there you go yeah um I
think it's crucially important this is
something that I struggle with I live in
Los Angeles which is a city that can at
times feel very alienating and isolating
but I'm very grateful that I have a come
to Austin baby yeah I know I'm thinking
about it but I I do have a I have a
friend a great friend group um which
you're obviously of course a part of but
I also have like my family close and I
feel super lucky and my heart goes out
to people who who don't have that but
yeah loneliness is and loneliness is not
being alone that's I think it's
important to make that decision it's
it's good to make friends with your mind
to the point that you can actually be
comfortably alone
but um but if you're not happy about it
you know if you if uh you feel like your
social life is lacking it's defitely
story that you tell yourself again right
like we said about about the food it's
not just the food that you eat it's not
just the relationships you have it's the
story that you tell yourself what does
it mean that this is the case what do
you think that your mom would think
about what you've done to your life now
about your work about the way that
you're influencing people about this
film what do you think she would she
would think about it oh man well my mom
was my my biggest fan and uh yeah mine
mine is too she'll be listening I love
it I love it I mean yeah moms are the
best and I'm very lucky that I had a
great mom and a very kind mom and a mom
who raised me with like I think the best
values that you could raise a child with
um and I think that's why the people
that follow me follow me because they
know that Honesty Integrity is super
important to me and those are 100%
values that I got from my mom you know
like growing up in my household to be
called a liar was like the worst thing
the worst thing and um and so yeah she
like she was an incredible incredible
mom not perfect no Mom is uh no person
is but um but yeah she was she was
wonderful and she supported me from day1
she was you know I mean I come from a
very small Jewish family and my parents
grew up very poor and uh and they made
it for themselves they they teamed up
and they created a business and it led
to a really great childhood for me and
my brothers but she never pushed me into
any one career Direction like she wasn't
like I I definitely expressed interest
early on in wanting to go to the medical
school route to be a doctor but when I
pivoted out of that she she didn't give
me any any crap for it um which I'm
super grateful for she just allowed me
to pursue my passions and um so yeah I
think that she would be and she was she
saw my first book come out she was very
very proud of me and and you know it's
funny like you can never be a prophet in
your own land is a term I've heard
recently
well I I would try to tell my mom like
you know I would as I was learning I was
like trying to like come to my mom with
all these like new learnings and
insights and she adopted a lot of them
like you know she started exercising
more and you know which I think was
helpful and we you know I I got rid of
some of the more processed things in her
in her in her kitchen cupboards but
um but she would she would never listen
to me ironically when it was like me
just kind of talking to her from across
the K the dining room table it was only
when I got to go on shows like The Dr Oz
Show you
know that she would then start to
actually pay attention to what my son
has Dr Roz's steal of approval I'd
better listen to him now yeah there you
go um you're like messaging Dr Oz being
like yo uh I've just found something new
out and I know that my mom won't listen
to me would you mind if I come back on
because I need to tell her through the
television this is the only way that
this works yeah or even when it like
even if it's something that like I had
been telling her for months somebody
else would say it on the do show be like
Max I heard this guy talking about the
benefits of of Kombucha mom that was me
yeah uh yeah and you know it's really
interesting to me to see this this Arc
for you you know as somebody that's now
stepping in that's giving people
evidence-based very apart from the child
abuse thing which I actually think is
accurate but largely un sort of volatile
it's not tribal it's just look here's
some here's some evidence to do with it
as you wish I know it seems like
a it's like Alchemy right you take a
situation that wasn't very
good and then you turn it into something
which is like I don't know it's like the
the the progeny of this situation you
know the the the the Epitaph that's been
written is the nudging that You' have
done and you know think about how many
centuries L of human life has been added
because of the information that you and
the millions of people that have
listened to your podcast have learned
about like that's that's like [__]
insane that's crazy what a great tribute
to give to someone no it is it is insane
and it's and it's a I know that I have a
responsibility that I don't take lightly
and I I I continually remind my audience
that I'm not perfect um I don't I don't
claim to have all of the answers but I
do the best that I can and my life
circumstance has has and you know my
whether you want to call them innate or
whatever my my skill set and my passion
and the circumstance that I you know
endured with my mom has led to you know
I guess a certain uh knowledge base and
I feel like you have to do in life the
things that you can't not do and as
somebody who's really empathetic and
compassionate at the end of the day what
I was learning as I was going through
this with my mom I couldn't keep to
myself I had to share and I realized of
course along the way that I had an
aptitude for what I was doing I realized
that I enjoyed it and it started to
build a following and look I know that
there are some people out there that no
matter what I say will never listen to
me you know because I'm I don't have
credentials after my name and I'm fine
with that I'm not here for you you know
I'm here for the people who you know
have have seen my work who can feel my
integrity and those are the people that
I try to reach you know and like you
can't please everybody in life right
right like you're not pizza
so um so yeah so again I I try to do the
best that I can and I'm always learning
I'm always challenging my biases and my
assumptions and I try to align myself
with people that I think are are you
know who are in the space who are also
doing it from a place of benevolence
there are experts in the space who I
believe are not doing who are not
operating from a place of benevolence
you know but um but I I am I love what I
do and I I aspire to lead my audience
ultimately to a greater vision of life
and um and just super grateful that
honestly anybody's paying attention hell
yeah Max Lugia ladies and gentlemen
where should people go when's the film
out what date so we're looking for a
knock on wood we're looking for a q1 or
Q2 2024 release so at some point in
2024 we're hoping for a global
theatrical
release that's as much as I can say at
this juncture but um people can check
out little empty boxes.com we have a
trailer and people can join the
newsletter there I don't send out like
regular updates but anything
specifically related to the film people
can sign up you know for local
screenings and what have you to learn
how to become an advocate for the film
um they can sign up for that little
empty
boxes.com and then I have my own podcast
which hoping to get you on soon enough
we're going to do it I promise we're
going to do it it's called the Genius
life on all podcast apps and then I'm
super active on Instagram and Twitter
and all the places hell yeah Max I
appreciate you thank you man thanks
Chris thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode with Max you
will love my three-hour brand new
conversation with Dr Andrew huberman go
on T it